[Music]
foreign
don't be scared
we've met before
are you looking for Reagan are you
looking for Raven
thank God
what do you think evil is
tell you what I think it is
we're born in this world with Hope and
Dreams
and the desire to be happy
it's happening to my daughter too the
devil has one wish Wherever those girls
went they brought something back with
them
to make us lose faith I believe you can
help get our daughters back did you kill
it in us and the devil never gives up
she knows who I am
where's the other girl
[Music]
what you're doing here is
named people have died on both sides of
possession
Lola what is it baby
I'm right here I don't wanna go to hell
[Applause]
be strong
what did you do
one girl lives one girl dies
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]